monsieur le monsieur le Premier
ministre madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée
nationale madame la ministre en charge
des relations avec le Parlement que nous
sommes heureux d'accueillir
particulièrement découvrir beaucoup de
tête vous allez
voir monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président du
Conseil constitutionnel et et les
membres qui vous
accompagnent Monsieur Alain Jupé ancien
Premier ministre que je salue monsieur
le Président du Conseil économique
social et environnemental Mesdames et
Messieurs les vice-présidents queurs et
secrétaires des bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Présidents et présidente de commission
Mesdames et Messieurs les présidentes et
présidents de
groupe Mesdames et Messieurs les
Présidents et présidents de délégation
et de l'Office Parlementaire mes chers
collègues députés sénateur monsieur le
Président de l'Amicale du Sénat chers
ancien collègue mesdames et
messieurs Monsieur le Premier Ministre
merci de votre présence et félicit pour
votre nomination à cette haute
fonction comme vous me l'avez dit au
soir de votre nomination par le
Président de la République vous avez
avec le Sénat d'excellents souvenirs
d'échange débat
et plus particulièrement comme ministre
des comptes publics vous m'avez d
vouloir poursuivre dans cet état
d'esprit même si je note qu'aucun
sénateur n'a été appelé à ce jour à
participer au
gouvernement
la tâche qui vous attend n'est pas les
plus faciles et le Sénat
entend bien être un
acteur et que les engagements pris par
le gouvernement précédent soi aussi
tenus le Sénat porte la voix des
territoires et des élus locaux c'est
avec eux que nous devrons tous ensem
tracer de nouvelles perspectives pour
notre
pays 2024 devra donc est une année de
vérité de courage et d'action pour
engager le redressement de la France les
Français attendent des actes vous l'avez
dit ils attendent dans leur quotidien
les résultats d'une politique qui doit
savoir prioriser et
hiérarchiser
quatre
chantiers me paraissent
essentiel
l'école car tout commence par là
ce
matin si les chantiers engagés par vous
vont dans le bon sens vous l'avez dit
encore ce matin beaucoup reste à faire
on ne peut se résoudre alors que le
niveau moyen des élèves demeure aussi
insuffisant on ne peut se résoudre lors
que l'autorité les enseignants soit sans
cesse contesté l'école doit pouvoir
assurer sa mission de transmission des
savoirs à l'abri des menaces et dans le
respect absolu du principe de
laïcité la santé car l'accès des
Français aux soins est devenu trop
souvent difficile et sources d'inégalité
il s'agit de trouver ensemble et en
faisant confiance aux acteurs du système
de soin les moyens d'assurer sur tout le
territoire la permanence des soins de
faire en sorte que chacun puisse avoir
accès à une médecine de
qualité en lien avec les professionnels
nous devrons poursuivre le
décloisonnement et la
territorialisation de notre système de
santé le
logement trè chantier
la crise est là et je pense sincèrement
qu'elle n'est pas que conjoncturelle ou
temporaire et là il va falloir oser
elle doit faire l'objet de toute notre
attention car c'est de la vie
quotidienne des Français dont il
s'agit vie quotidienne c'est abriter sa
famille c'est trouvver une chambre près
de l'université c'est déménager pour
prendre un nouveau travail voilà des
préoccupations très concrètes pour
nombre de nos
concitoyens pour sortir de cette crise
il va falloir innover et repenser en
profondeur notre politique du logement
dans toutes ses dimensions une mission
d'analyse est en cours au Sénat elle
fera des
propositions je vous le disje
sincèrement on ne réussira que par la
décentralisation en desserrant les
contraintes et en nous appuyant sur les
élus locaux au premier rang desquels les
maires pour une mise en œuvre adaptée
aux spécificités les territoires et aux
besoins de leurs habitants là aussi la
verticalité l'uniformité et le XXL nous
conduisent à l'échec
[Applaudissements]
d'aujourd'hui la décentralisation là
aussi nous l'avons évoqué on ne peut
plus attendre je l'ai dit au président
de la République lors des rencontres de
saintis j'ai de l'estime pour Eric
à qui le président de la République a
confié une nouvelle mission pour faire
des propositions mais je crois que le
temps n'est plus aux
mission le temps est à la décision le
temps est à
l'action l'ensemble des associations
d'élus a fait des recommandations le
Sénat a publié un rapport fruit d'un
travail collectif transpartisan de plus
de 8 mois formulant 15 propositions pour
rendre aux élus locaux leur pouvoir
d'agir avec un objectif redonner tout
son sens au principe de libre
administration des collectivités avec un
fil rouge qui Monsieur béchus S
souviendra fait l'objet et oui d'une
charte la
simplification pour lutter contre cette
inflation normative qui étouffe et avec
un levier indispensable le retour d'une
part d'autonomie financière et
fiscale seul des résultats concrets dans
la proximité permettront de gagner la
confiance des Français et d'engager la
France sur la voie du
redressement et Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pour conduire tous ces
chantiers on a besoin de continuité et
on a besoin d'une vision de moyen
terme s'agissant des finances publiques
nous l'avons aussi évoqué ce matin
l'année 2024 devra poser les actes pour
sortir notre pays de la dérive
financière ce n'est pas un souhait mais
une exigence il en va de la souveraineté
de la France et de sa crédibilité
internationale je veux être clair la
France doit adopter une gestion plus
rigoureuse et plus efficace de l'argent
public nous devons dégager les moyens
pour préparer l'avenir et baisser la
pression fiscale qui pè sur les
entreprises et le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages nous devons encourager les
Français qui travaillent monsieur le
Premier ministre et qui s'engagent pour
notre pays mais de se désespère de voir
leurs efforts aussi peu récompenser
lors de l'examin du projet de loi de
programmation des finances
publiques le Sénat a proposé une
trajectoire plus ambitieuse de réduction
du déficit et de la dette il n'a pas été
écouté nous avons proposé dans le budget
2024 7 milliards d'économie afin
d'engager concrètement dès cette année
le redressement structurel des comptes
publics nous navons pas été écouté pas
une de ces propositions n'a été reprise
par le gouvernement qui avait pourtant
lui-même appelé à des économies
supplémentaires je le regrette
sincèrement Monsieur le Premier Ministre
j'ai dit à Madame Élisabeth Bor qui
n'était pas acceptable de voir ignorer
par le 493 des semaines de travail et
des centaines de proposition sérieuse et
[Applaudissements]
responsable le recours au 493 était
prévu dans notre Constitution pour
conclure un débat par ire qui ne peut
aboutir autrement pas pour l'occulter ou
il couper cours il en va de la vitalité
de notre démocratie et de la confiance
des citoyens dans le bon fonctionnement
de nos institutions faut-il rappeler que
c'est le Parlement qui vote la loi et
pas l'administration de
Bercy je souhaite que cette année nous
puissions avoir sur lesj financiers je
vous fais
confiance mais pas seulement sur eux un
dialogue plus interactif entre le
Parlement madame la
Présidente et
l'exécutif
2023 fut une année d'élection
sénatoriale ce rendez-vous démocratique
a permis de renouveler 95 de nos
collègues et d'accueillir au Palais du
Luxembourg
75 nouvelle sénatrice et nouveau
sénateurs au service des territoires et
de nos concitoyens je souhaite vous
redire mes chers collègues mon
engagement total pour ces TR années à
venir fort de votre confiance et chaque
renouvellement est l'occasion de se
refonder donc
méfiez-vous
2024 sera une nouvelle année forte pour
le
bécamériste madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale jeis saluer votre
présence je suis attaché à la qualité de
nos échanges qui participe au dialogue
démocratique entre nos deux chambres
nous avons des différences mais nous
savons aussi dans l'intérêt de la nation
avoir des convergences et parfois nos
échanges nous mène de la rue de
l'Université à la rue de vauirard avec
plus de 100000 personnes à nos côtés
comme le 12 novembre dernier nous avons
parler d'une même voix contre
l'antisémitisme et pour les valeurs de
la République j'avais conclu cette
marche par ces mots
après la marche la démarche nous y
travaillons je pense notamment à la
place et à la conception de la laïcité
qui ne peut souffrir je le dis
clairement
d'accommodement l'année qui s'est
achevée a montré combien le bicamérisme
était indispensable à l'équilibre de nos
institutions et particulièrement dans le
moment politique que nous vivons vous
l'avez rappelé madame la Présidente sans
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale Michel Debray anticipé ce rôle
spécifique du Sénat dès
1958 en présentant le projet de
constitution de la 5e République devant
le Conseil d'État je vais
citer il est facile de comprendre
pourquoi il faut à la France une
puissante deuxe chambre c'est de Michel
Debray c'est pas de
moi notre régime électoral peut nous
empêcher de connaître les majorités
cohérentes qui assurent sans règle
détaillée la bonne marche du régime
parlementaire fin de citation précience
de ce que nous vivons depuis juin
2022 l'an dernier ici même je vous avais
dit que nous allons vivre le temps du
Parlement reposant sur un dialogue entre
exécutif Assemblée nationale et
Sénat ce fut parfois tonique parfois
très tonique je pense bien sûr à la
réforme des retraites au projet de loi
immigration intégration asile ce
dialogue est parfois difficile mais il
est essentiel dans une démocratie
parlementaire nous avons constaté
aussi combien les commissions mixtes
paritaires jouent un rôle décisif et
renouvelé je le dis vraiment avec
respect pour l'Assemblée nationale voilà
pourquoi je souhaite qu'elle demeure un
véritable lieu de dialogue à la fois
apaisé conforme à notre rôle de
législateur au service des Français et
des territoires et bien entendu après un
réel débat dans chaque
chambre madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale peut-être
pourrions-nous émettre un vœu commun en
direction du Premier
ministre
est
attention à la multiplication des
textes attention à l'abus des procédures
accélérées
ou à la convocation des commissions
mixtes paritaires en urgence comme en
descembre bien légiféré nécessite temps
et
réflexion permettez-moi de m'adresser
plus spécifiquement à mes collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs et de saluer les
anciens sénateurs nombreux présents ce
soir ici ce qui marque leur attachement
à notre institution
oui maises vœux s'adresse à vous vous
qui enrichissez nos débats de vos
interventions et de vos travaux de votre
action sur le terrain en métropole dans
nos
et auprès de nos compatriotes établis
hors de France mais s'adress à vous mes
chers collègues membres du bureau et de
la Conférence des Présidents avec qui
nous partageons le souci commun de
l'institution
sénatoriale s'adresse au commissions et
aux délégations qui sont le carburant de
nos travaux mais s'adresse au président
et présidents de groupes Politi car je
le répète nous sommes une assemblée
politique et c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel oui chacune et chacun
d'entre vous participer à faire du Sénat
aujourd'hui et demain un acteur clé au
service de la démocratie parlementaire
car n'oublions pas que la 5e République
est un régime parlementaire sa pratique
le fait parfois un peu
oublié chers collègues sénatrices et
sénateurs grâce à vous l'exigence
législative du Sénat a été au
rendez-vous au rendez-vous de 2003 et
notre Assemblée a imprimé sa marque o de
cette réforme des retraites et la loi
immigration intégration asile sur un
certain nombre de textes je pense au
projet de loi de programmation et
d'orientation du ministère de la Justice
du projet de loi pour le plein emploi du
projet de loi relatif à la programmation
militaire du projet de loi et les
projets de loi liés aux énergies
nucléaires et renouvelables les
propositions de loi vous le Rappelz
madame la Présidente ce midi ont pris
une vigueur particulière je pense
notamment à celle concernant le rôle des
maires dans l'attribution des logements
sociaux la valorisation du métier de
secrétaire de mairie quelque chose de
très important sur le terrain et et dans
le territoire la sécurité des élus
locaux et la protection des maires dont
le thème du dernier congrès commune
attaqué République menacée a montré
toute son actualité très bientôt seront
déposé les propositions de loi qui
feront suite au rapport sénatorial sur
la
décentralisation le Sénat a assumé sa
mission essentielle de contrôle des
missions d'information et des
commissions d'enquête rendront leurs
travaux notamment sur le signalement et
le traitement des pressions menaces et
agressions dont les enseignants sont
victimes et ce qui s'est passé à ras
nous rappelle à cette
exigence le suivi de la préparation des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris les émeutes sur lequel nous
conduisons avec la commission des lois
un travail en profondeur l'impact du
narcotrafic la mission conjointe de
contrôle sur les terribles inondations
de novembre dernier et de janvier elle
va se mettre au travail à partir de la
semaine prochaine et nous
maintenons monsieur le ministre Béchu
notre vigilance sur le zéro
artificialisation net et sa mise en
œuvre
concrète
avec la reprise de la session
parlementaire notre ordre du jour devra
être je l'espère bientôt connu Monsieur
le Premier Ministre madame la ministre
en charge des relations avec le
Parlement nous annoncer l'avenir de
l'agriculture les violences
intrafamiliales la justice des mineur
les mesures judiciaires de sûreté
applicaes au condamnés terroristes la
gouvernance de la sûreté nucléaire ou
encore projet de loi relative à la
souveraineté
énergétique j'ai aussi à l'esprit les
textes annoncés qui touchent à des
questions éthiques les soins palliatifs
et la fin de vie pour lequel je le dis
je souhaite deux textes distincts et des
débats qui se déroulent dans le respect
de la conscience de
chacun la Constitution de
1958 a permis à la 5e République de
traverser de multiples épreuves
politiques elle est garante de la
stabilité de nos institutions
commeécrivait montesquieux dans une
formule souvent citée mais trop rarement
médité il ne faut toucher au lois et à
forcierie à la constitution que d'une
main tremblante mais si le président de
la République nous présente un projet de
révision qui a pour objectif de mieux
répondre aux attentes de nos concitoyens
d'innover en matière de décentralisation
nous l'aborderons avec sérieux et
objectivité je pense notamment à la
NouvelleCalédonie sans attendre la mise
en uvre effective des annonces de 2022
du président de la République j'ai
souhaité relancer la notre réflexion
institutionnelle avec l'ensemble des
groupes politiques pourquoi parce qu'en
matière constitutionnelle nous le savons
tous le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale
ont les mêmes pouvoirs ce n'est pas un
pouvoir de véau concédé au Sénat comme
je l'ai lu parfois pour le Constitution
de 1958 c'est une manière s'assurer
qu'on ninstrumentalise pas la
Constitution à les fins partisanes ou de
communication donc si nous prenons les
devants de la réflexion sur les
institutions c'est pour faire entendre
notre voix au printemps avec pour
rapporteur général le président de la
commission des lois et bien le groupe de
travail rendra publ ses conclusions
elles permettront d'enrichir le débat et
préciseront la position du Sénat sur le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie en
ces temps de doute d'absention il
s'agira de l'élection présidentielle du
cumul des mandats du référendum de la
justice mais aussi de l'évolution
institutionnel outreem sujet important
pour nous ou encore du statut de l'élu
outreem statut de l'élu deux sujets sur
ces deux sujets notre mission de
représentant des collectivités
territoriales nous confèt une
responsabilité particulière les appels à
la différenciation les constats d'une
pénalisation croissante de la vie
publique et politique sont anciens nous
devons apporter des solutions concrètes
aux élus au au territoire et pas
nécessairement toujours par un grand
mécano institutionnel parfois tout
simplement en changeant les
pratiques au plan
international 2023 aura vu la
convergence d'une multiplication des
tensions internationales
oui la perte d'influence relative du
monde
occidental et le recul de ces valeurs au
premierers rang desquels la démocratie a
fait les pays de l'Union européenne dans
ce contexte la diplomatie parlementaire
prouve son utilité notre assemblée aura
démontré en 2023 le sens des
responsabilités avec lequel elle remplit
son rôle on doit au travaux de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces
armées de la commission des affaires
européennes mais aussi au groupe
d'amitié on le doit au résolutions voté
celle sur l'Arménie pour dénoncer
l'appétite conquête de puissan voisine
et appeler à la mobilisation
internationale sur l'Ukraine pour que
les crimes commis par l'agresseur russe
soi
sanctionnés il est révélateur que le roi
Charles II a choisi le Parlement pour
prononcer devant députés et sénateurs
son discours public sur la relation
entre le Royaume-Uni la France et
l'Europe nous avons démontré en décembre
avec les présidents des groupes
politiques du Sénat en nous rendant en
Israël et dans les Territoires
palestiniens que sur des sujets
difficile et douloureux qui nous
bouleverse le Sénat était capable
d'écouter et de porter une parole qui
puisse être
partagé en 2024 nous ne sommes
malheureusement pas à l'abri de crise
qui se surrajoute aux crise actuel dans
ce contexte d'instabilité où la voix de
la France est à la fois attendue mais
affaibli le Sénat a une responsabilité
particulière continuer sur tous les
continents renforcer ses relations avec
ses alliés traditionnels c'est vrai au
proche- Orient où les Libanais qui sont
un peu à
l'abandon ont tant besoin d'un
engagement accru de la France c'est
particulièrement vrai en Afrique où 2023
est été marqué par le REP de notre
influence et de notre
présence nos amis attendent notre pays
ne considérons pas leur soutien comme
acquis considérons-les tels qu'ils sont
et non tel que nous souhaiterions qu'il
soit
demain l'agenda de 2024 sera marqué par
les élections européennes dans la
diversité de nos convictions sur
l'Europe il nous appartiendra de faire
valoir la place des parlements nationaux
vu de Bruxelles ils sont parfois
considérés comme des
obstacles je soutiens au contraire
qu'ils sont une partie de la solution
pour rapprocher l'Europe des citoyens et
apporter des réponses moins
technocratique j'adresse un salut
particulier aux Français de l'étranger
et à leurs élus ceux qui ont vécu à
l'étranger savent bien que l'éloignement
n'est jamais une sinineécure il faut
mieux adapter notre législation à la
spécificité de leur situation ayons à
l'esprit que nombre de nos compatriotes
vivant à l'étranger sont confrontés à
des situations
parfois d'insécurité forte et sont
victime de violen les plus abjectes je
pense ce soir à nos 41 compatriotes
assassinés lors de l'attaque terroriste
du Hamas le 7 octobre et à nos trois
compatriotes portés disparus ou encore
retenu en otage un hommage national doit
leur être rendu comme à toutes les
victimes du
terrorisme c'est
donc
c'est donc un sénat volontaire ouvert
avec une majorité solide dans sa
diversité un sénat attaché au respect
des groupes d'opposition et minoritaire
un sénat attentif aux préoccupations et
aux attentes du territoire un sénat qui
croit au redressement de notre pays et à
la nécessité d'agir un sénat qui ne
transige pas sur le respect des
principes de la démocratie parlementaire
je voudrais avoir un mot comme la
présidente ce matin une pensée
particulière pour nos compatriotes
réunionnés qui subissent actuellement
les conséquences du très violent cyclone
Béal je pense bien sûr au secours
mobilisés et aux élus locaux qui sont là
encore en première ligne pour
reconstruire mais aussi mes pensé voir
nos compatriotes du pas decalis nous
leur avions rendu visite au mois de
décembre qui depuis plus de 2 mois font
face à des inondations dévastatrice
alors en cette année olympique et
paralympique qui doit nous rassembler
c'est le courage et la volonté de faire
qui devront nous guider et permettre de
nous dépasser et aussi d'en faire un
moment d'unité nationale un moment de
bonheur un moment de rencontre un moment
de
partage au fond je vais vous dire ce que
j'entends le soir dans les vœux
notamment du département des
Yvelines nous l'entendons répéter la
devise du Comité olympique plus vite
plus ha plus fort ensemble alors c'est
ce que je souhaite voir appliquer à
notre pays pour cette année
2024 très bonne année à chacune et à
chacun très bonne année à vous Monsieur
le Premier Ministre très bonne année à
vous madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale très bonne annéees chers
collègues très bonne année au Sénat très
bonne année à la
[Applaudissements]
France
surprise boire avec vous voilà la
vre